[Música]
la pizza fue durante años la peor
pesadilla para los soldados franceses en
afganistán y sufrieron su mayor número
de bajas francia desplegó sus tropas
entre 2001 y 2014 y de sus 89 militares
caídos en territorio afgano 54
fallecieron en esta provincia es
sumamente infiltrada por los rebeldes
además de apoyar al ejército afgano
contra la insurrección talibán francia
participó en el desarrollo de esta
región mayoritariamente agrícola y
reconocida por su progresismo cómo ha
evolucionado la situación después de la
salida de las tropas francesas y qué
lecciones se pueden obtener ahora que la
coalición internacional considera
retirarse de afganistán nuestros
reporteros visitaron la región
esto es boleto de vuelta a capital
[Música]
y kapisa una provincia indomable que se
extiende al noreste de kabul entre 2008
y 2012 albergó a la mayoría de las
fuerzas francesas desde hace cerca de 40
años el combatientes que luchan por
estas llanuras desiertas ya sean miembro
de la guerrilla talibán o de las fuerzas
regulares afganas hace ya seis años que
estos soldados afganos garantizan solos
la seguridad del distrito los encabeza
el capitán ali mardan amiri
[Música]
para bajar nos dirigimos al puesto
avanzado de la colina andan en la línea
de frente a donde se encuentran los
talibán
a 5 kilómetros de aquí quiero meter
todas las duras sanas móvil
los talibanes están en efecto a unos
cuantos kilómetros estos pueblos siguen
estando bajo el control del gobierno
este es el último puesto militar del
distrito ubicado en esta cima
esta última delimita la línea de frente
hay pocos puestos de control en esta
zona esta montaña a la que estamos está
bajo el control del ejército afgano y
más abajo hasta el pueblo guayanés donde
se encuentran los talibán
dos semanas
allá está la colina afgana donde están
nuestros enemigos los talibán así porque
abajo la zona estaba hasta hace poco
bajo el control del gobierno desde que
el ejército extranjero se fue solo queda
este puesto avanzado mientras antes
había uno aquí en high and y otro allá
en dora je pero ahora la zona no está
segura aquí los ataques son cotidianos
estos hombres acaban de vivir una noche
difícil son soldados como pasaron las
tres últimas noches
los talibán nos atacan todo el tiempo
dicen que quieren paz pero es falso y lo
sabíamos desde el principio sabíamos a
qué atenernos estamos en el frente todos
los días
durante estos tres últimos días no han
parado de disparar nos nos atacan todas
las noches
están solos para repeler las embestidas
talibán desde que las tropas francesas
se fueron de kapisa en 2012 la situación
en materia de seguridad se degradó
fuertemente
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la provincia tenía la reputación de ser
la zona de despliegue más difícil para
los soldados franceses de hecho es la
zona en la que francia perdió más
soldados más del 60 por ciento de los 89
soldados franceses muertos en afganistán
desde el 2001 perecieron en esta región
la base de mi rap es la última que
ocupan los franceses en kapisa
hoy unos sesenta soldados afganos cuidan
la base de la presencia francesa solo
les quedan containers
cuando los franceses abandonaron la base
dejaron todo y sólo se llevaron sus
armas y sus municiones y todo lo que ven
aquí pertenecía a los franceses cuando
se fueron cogimos las carpas y trajimos
acá lo que había para protegerlos de la
lluvia dejaron
[Música]
nuestra electricidad no es
suficientemente potente para poder usar
estos aparatos los soldados franceses
tenían una planta potente y nosotros no
entonces no podemos usar nada de lo que
hay aquí
además del apoyo en materia de seguridad
de las tropas francesas kapisa contó con
varios proyectos de desarrollo
financiados por francia su cría nazi y
es miembro del consejo provincia no de
kapisa 40 años soltera un estatus poco
común para una mujer afgana se da por
misión censar los problemas encontrados
por la población le acompañamos hoy al
hospital de la provincia apoyado en
parte financiera por el estado francés
[Música]
mire el estado en que está el agua cae
del techo va a caer
mire este trabajo
respaldo
hicieron un mal trabajo y nada es de
calidad mire
vine a contar todo lo que no funciona en
este hospital hay tantas cosas por hacer
la edificación necesita reparaciones hay
graves problemas en los servicios de
cirugía y pediátricos
es mi trabajo ocuparme de esto como
miembro del consejo provincial
como representante local somos un puente
entre el pueblo y el gobierno de habla
el deterioro es alarmante en los
diferentes servicios del hospital dos
años después del final de su
construcción
la edificación empezaba a caerse a
pedazos tengan a mary como estas hijo
mío tuvo bien
como vas ni querido sohail que ocurre es
que su cuerpo se hinchado y vomitado
y el paciente se llama soja y tiene 16
meses sufre de diarrea aguda y neumonía
cuando hace frío y hay humedad en el
interior los niños se enferman
rápidamente es lo que ocurre en esta
habitación por ejemplo hay mucha humedad
es todo lo que podemos ofrecer como
lugar de acogida para las consultas no
tenemos alternativa es nuestro servicio
pediátrico en envase actual bordar formó
anillas
[Música]
al final del día sucre a nacer y nos
lleva donde su familia reunida para una
cita cotidiana 80% de la población de la
pizza tiene un acceso limitado a la
electricidad entonces a las 6 de la
tarde donde su primo ni ravi no falta
nadie
se volvió una energía bajo más bajo
[Música]
contamos con energía a partir de las 6
de la tarde nos las quitan estalvis unos
dejar partir sólo la podemos usar para
iluminación y televisión el voltaje no
es lo suficientemente potente para una
estufa eléctrica tampoco para usar una
plancha
al batatas mate hasta para que la
provincia de mi rap está dividida en
cinco llanuras nuestro pueblo está al
costado de la llanura cariño nos
encontramos del lado del río donde no
hay electricidad permanentemente en
frente al otro lado dos mil quinientas
casas cuentan con la energía 24 horas
los siete días de la semana la energía
es conducida por estos pilotes esta
estación eléctrica fue financiada por
francia pero en la medida en que los
proyectos de electrificación no fueron
continuados por las autoridades afganas
tan sólo el 15 por ciento de la
provincia tiene acceso a electricidad al
día de hoy sucre anasiri acude al
consejo provincial no se desplazan nunca
sin sus guardaespaldas la situación en
materia de seguridad ha empeorado es por
ello que el presidente afgano ordenó que
cada miembro de los consejos
provinciales cuente cada uno con tres
guardaespaldas importa me amenazaron en
varias oportunidades desarrollar es la
razón por la cual no me desplazo sin mi
guardaespaldas hoy el consejo se reúne
para hablar sobre las dificultades de la
población en la región
avalamos bolsitas de una múltiple que
fui a visitar el hospital de las
cincuenta camas de mi hija la
edificación está deteriorada hay muchos
problemas relacionados con la
infraestructura que boca había pedazos
de pared que se caían filtraciones en el
techo
[Música]
francia nos había ayudado con 61 5
millones de euros
buenos días
estas ayudas estaban destinadas al
distrito de tagab migran al asad y
surubí
creo que de esos 60 y 15 millones de
euros no más de 10 millones de euros
fueron invertidos en estos cuatro
distritos no sé lo que ocurrió con esos
millones de euros porque no se hizo nada
es difícil saber cómo fueron invertidos
estos 61 millones de euros tirados por
francia para el desarrollo de la
provincia
no podemos consultar las auditorías
anuales realizadas por la agencia
francesa para el desarrollo kapisa es
una provincia reconocida por su
progresismo donde la escolaridad de las
niñas es impulsada a diferencia de otras
provincias como en esta escuela
financiada por francia nos encontramos
en la escuela de mujeres jazz insight
esta escuela fue construida gracias a
donaciones del gobierno francés tal como
lo puede ver la construcción de esta
escuela culminó en 2014
[Música]
les puedo entrar
tienen problemas para venir a la escuela
algunos de ustedes son amenazadas por
los talibán sé que algunas mujeres que
estudian aquí son originarias de los
distritos de alasai y afcan ya porque
allá no hay escuelas sé que enfrentan
numerosas dificultades dónde están
esta adolescente tomar riesgos
diariamente para venir a estudiar viene
de un distrito en parte disputado por
los talibán no hay escuela donde vivo es
así desde hace algunos años la gente del
pueblo no quiere dejarnos ir a la
escuela queremos ir sin embargo pero
nadie nos deja estudiar con frecuencia
hay combates y las escuelas están
cerradas para venir hasta aquí
enfrentamos muchos problemas
llevamos la burka en las zonas
controladas por los talibanes y en
cuanto salimos nos la quitamos y sólo
conservamos el velo
si descubren que vinimos a la escuela
corremos el riesgo de ser amenazadas
pero también pueden matarnos debido a
ello
el sur de la provincia vive bajo amplia
influencia de los rebeldes han ganado
terreno desde que las fuerzas
extranjeras se fueron de la región en
2014 los esfuerzos continúan en la base
militar de mi rap los soldados siguen
recibiendo diariamente clases de
artillería así hay actualmente
negociaciones de paz entre el talibán y
el gobierno la incertidumbre sobre el
futuro invita a la precaución tras la
caída de los talibán el país fue
reconstruido con mucha dificultad no
queremos perder el gobierno que tenemos
hoy en día los talibán son afganos como
nosotros y los acogeremos si quieren
unirse a nosotros si vienen a hacer la
paz los acogeremos pero si quiere
tomarse el poder por la fuerza no los
dejaremos antes sólo teníamos
kalashnikov hoy en día contamos con
armamento pesado armas ligeras y
modernas para defender nuestro país
pero los talibán estarían disputándole
al gobierno más de la mitad del
territorio un país que las fuerzas
extranjeras podrían abandonar
definitivamente antes de la próxima
primavera
[Música]
hasta aquí boleto de vuelta a la pista
si desea ver nuevamente este reportaje
lo invitamos a visitar france24 puntocom
[Música]